[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new flash flashpoint
video in Justice League Easter eggs we
just got some big news about what's
going on with the flash movies so we'll
break it all down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos will do a new Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your
predictions for the flash flashpoint
movie on the video so starting with the
big stuff first number five several news
sites have reported in the last couple
of days that Jeffrey Dean Morgan is
currently in the process of closing a
deal to star in the new flash movie as
the version of Thomas Wayne from Justice
League flashpoint
if you're not a big comic book reader or
you haven't seen any of the fan art of
him in the past few years that would
make him
flashpoint Batman who she's dead I
watched him die probably one of the
coolest alternate versions of Batman in
the multiverse from the comics and if
you didn't know Warner Brothers and the
last few directors to attempt to make a
flash movie the last couple of years
have all confirmed that they were doing
versions of the Justice League
flashpoint storyline for the plot of the
flash movie is one of the most famous
flash stories of all time one of the
most famous DC Comics stories of all
time so no big surprises they would want
to attempt it with a flash movie but
Batman in the flashpoint timeline isn't
Bruce Wayne because in that version of
events Bruce is the only one killed in
Crime Alley by Joe Chill and Thomas and
Martha Wayne his parents were the ones
who survived and he gets his own version
of a Batman origin story Martha Wayne
becomes the flashpoint version of the
Joker being driven mad by Bruce's death
so flashpoint is meant to be the darkest
timeline outcome as a way to twist the
metaphorical knife in the Flash's back
for having dared to try and cheat fate
by using time-travel to try and save his
mother from being killed by
reverse-flash Jeffrey Dean Morgan is
known for playing very hardcore
characters most people think of the
comedian when they think of his comic
book characters he even took a picture
of himself wearing his comedian mask
from The Watchmen movie a while ago
there was a great Justice League
flashpoint animated movie DC did a long
time ago that all referenced throughout
this video along with Justice League
apocalypse war because that movie also
contained a second flashpoint event and
there's some similarities in the Justice
League apocalypse war movie to the
plans that Zack Snyder had for his
Justice League movies in sequels when
they were still doing a trilogy there
was going to be a version of a
flashpoint in Future Justice League
sequels where they tried to alter the
past to avoid dark side taking over the
earth so number four there are a lot of
questions about how this flashpoint
storyline in the flash movie is using
the Justice League movie in Batman's DC
EU story because as you all know Jeffrey
Dean Morgan played Thomas Wayne in
Batman V Superman lauren cohan played
Martha Wayne both actors from the
walking dead coincidentally they were
only in that opening scene depicting the
iconic Batman Crime Alley origin story
we all saw a version of that play out at
the end of the Joker movie too recently
they do a version of this and pretty
much every single new Batman franchise
when they reboot with a new actor
hopefully Matt Reeves finds a fresh way
of addressing it in the Batman movie
next year with Robert Pattinson because
I don't think we need to see this scene
exactly like this again right after
seeing it in the Joker movie but if
they're even thinking about using
Jeffrey Dean Morgan Thomas Wayne as
flashpoint Batman the movie also has to
address Ben Affleck's Batman in some way
the whole point in doing flashpoint
Batman is the payoff scene with Bruce
wayne/batman at the end where he finally
gets to read his father's message again
after not having heard from him since
his death when he was a child acts so
much of a punch it's such a huge payoff
for the Batman character so you can't
just do thomas wayne batman without
having some kind of Bruce Wayne bookend
at the end of the movie but there hasn't
been any recent talk of Ben Affleck
having a cameo scene in the flash movie
so hopefully they can get him to come
back for a cameo scene the only Batman
stuff that we know that he's coming back
for right now is just to do additional
voiceover dialogue for the Justice
League
Snyder cut that they're releasing next
year but that's very different from him
doing a full blown cameo scene in a
future DC movie number 3 as for a lauren
cohan Joker there hasn't been any talk
of including her version of the
character and when the flash movie
producers said that they're doing a
different version of the Justice League
flashpoint storyline they were saying
that it would be much smaller and
self-contained than the original story
the original flashpoint was a huge
Justice League universe spanning story
featuring all of the Justice League
characters including Hal Jordan Green
Lantern as well as most of the other
major DC comic book characters DC Comics
used the of
to reboot their entire comic book
universe to the new 52 the problem with
doing that in the movies as most people
have realized is that owner to do a
comic book accurate version you'd have
to make it a full-blown Justice League
sequel and it would be less of a flash
movie at that point it would cost 250
million dollars in right now Warner
Brothers is just way too scared to make
a Justice League sequel right away I've
already done a couple of videos about
that patty Jenkins revealed that behind
the scenes their new movie strategy is
all about just doing solo movies one at
a time for the characters smaller stuff
building up to another Justice League
way down the road which i think is the
right way to do it so smaller flashpoint
just means that most of the alternate
versions of the characters will probably
see will be flashed specific characters
with maybe a few bigger Justice League
crossover characters Thomas Wayne Batman
would be one of those the flash movie
producers also confirmed recently this
cyborg would be featured during the
movie she didn't say how much cyborg
would be in it only that he would be in
there somewhere the flash spends most of
his time studying the Speed Force at
STAR Labs doing research cyborg father
runs STAR Labs in the DC EU so it's a
natural fit also in that original
version of Zack Snyder's Justice League
sequels in one of the movies the flash
teams up with cyborg to crack the
science of time-travel together using
the Speed Force so that he can go back
and warn Batman flashpoint is a time
travel story so it's easy to justify
cyborg helping the flash make necessary
calculations number two the Justice
League Snyder cut that's coming out next
year won't change a lot about what
they're doing with the flash movie
Andy machete from the it movies is the
one that's doing the flash movie now he
pretty much has free rein to do what he
wants with the character he can include
as much or as little of the Justice
League Snyder cut stuff as he wants I
haven't heard anything about him having
conversations with Zack Snyder about his
original vision for how the flash
character would develop through his
Justice League sequels the Snyder cut is
supposed to be over four hours long so
I'm assuming that even though they're
not gonna be doing that Justice League
sequels they'll at least address some of
that flash time-travel scene from Batman
V Superman and some of their
conversations even if they don't spend a
lot of time dealing with that so going
into the flash movie he will have
already time traveled at some point but
they'll have to have a funny way of
explaining it because technically Bay
and the rules of time-travel this
version of the flash will not have
experienced that yet so because a lot of
flashpoint is based on mistakes that the
flash makes I think that'll all just
play into the movie the ending of the
Justice League Snyder cut will be
different from the theatrical cut but
for the most part emotionally the flash
will be in the same place so going into
the beginning of the events of the Flash
movie Barry's father is still in jail
framed for his mother's death by
reverse-flash they haven't cast that
reverse-flash yet I know everybody has a
lot of fan cast the actor who plays
homeland Iran the boys would make a
fantastic
reverse-flash and I managed to squeeze
the truth out of him he's the main
villain of flashpoint
so it's a safe bet that they'll do him
right out of the gate but they haven't
confirmed officially that they will do
reverse-flash there was a version of the
movie at one point that heavily featured
the core flash rogues led by Captain
Cold I don't know they're gonna be
featured in the new movie but it's a
safe bet that they'll at least be a
reference and I'm assuming if the movie
does well enough they'll continue with
Ezra Miller in the sequels I know
there's a lot of questions about him
just because it's been pretty quiet
recently but as far as we know he is
still playing the flash until told
otherwise the number one big question
everyone has what about changing Batman
in the DC EU and how are they gonna
handle Batman in the next Justice League
if they ever get around to making it
most of what Matt Reeves has said the
last year implies that he isn't really
thinking about any kind of giant Justice
League story line or a crossover or
overarching universe spanning storyline
with his new Batman trilogy he's just
thinking about Batman characters in
Gotham City and it sounds like Warner
Brothers doesn't have any concrete plan
for how to handle Batman in the next
Justice League movie or real plan for
another Justice League movie at all
right now they're just gonna wait and
see how the next round of movies goes
then they'll come back to the table and
figure it out so if there's any DC EU
Batman at the end of the flash movie to
bookend things I think it would have to
be Ben Affleck's Batman and then that
would be his actual final appearance as
the character it would be the best way
to send his character off with this
scene here of him reading his father's
message now that doesn't solve the
problem of explaining new Batman in the
next Justice League but that movie is
probably at least five years away from
getting made so it's not really
worth worrying about too much right now
but if we hear any more news about that
of course I'll do a video post all your
video requests in the comments below
congratulations to the one you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details
everyone click here for my Justice
League Snyder cut trailer video and
click here to learn about the new
version of the Joker that they're
supposedly going to introduce in the new
Batman movies thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you